ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: There's quite a
bit I want to go through here.
so we're going to talk
today about modulation,
which you've already
gotten some notion of,
and that's basically the task
of matching a transmitted signal
to the physical medium.
And then we'll talk about
demodulation, as well.
Whoops.
So just to remind you of
how we got into this story,
we started off
talking about bits
that we had to get across
to a receiver from a source.
And we've been spending
quite some time
now focusing on this
piece of the system, which
is taking the bits,
converting them
to actual physical
samples of a voltage,
for instance, and then
trying to get them
over some physical medium.
And then, at the other end,
converting back to bits,
all right?
So this is really a key
piece of the system.
If you can't get it over
the physical medium,
then you don't have anything.
So we've been spending
quite some time on that.
We've talked about models
for signals and models
for systems, LTI
models for systems,
all in the time domain.
And then we came to the
frequency domain, which
we said will make
things a lot simpler,
and actually is the way that
people think about transmission
on physical media, typically.
OK, so the actual math.
Well, we've seen--
this is just review.
We've seen that, most
recently, that you can actually
represent any signal as
a weighted combination
of exponentials, so this
was the transform domain
representation.
And the weights here were given
by the discrete-time Fourier
transform.
So you give me a signal,
I can find for you
the discrete-time Fourier
transform, which then tells me
how to assemble complex
exponentials to get
the signal of
interest, all right?
And so this Fourier
representation of the signal
is really the frequency
domain thinking.
And then we saw how to apply
that actually to a system.
We have an LTI system,
therefore characterized
by a frequency response.
We first introduced
the frequency response
as a way of thinking about
what happens to cosines.
Put a cosine in,
and you get a cosine
out that's scaled by the
magnitude of the frequency
response and with
the phase shifted
by the angle of the
frequency response.
And then we went from
cosines, or in parallel we
talked about exponential
inputs, so inputs of this type.
And now we have more
generally a signal
that's represented as a weighted
combination of exponentials
of that type.
Out comes the same weighted
combination of exponentials,
except each one is
scaled by the frequency
response as appropriate.
And then comparing
that with what
we expect as a spectral
representation for the output.
We get this key
relationship, which
is relating the input and
the output of a system,
an LTI system, that's governed
by a frequency response.
So now we're starting
to think in terms
of the spectral content of
the input, all right, which
is the frequency domain
description of the signal that
goes into the system.
Then the frequency
response of the system
shaping that spectral content
to give you the spectral content
of what comes out, all right?
So this is the language
and the picture
that we have, and it's all
as simple as multiplication
once you've figured out
what the spectral content is
of the signal of interest,
once you have the frequency
response of the system.
So we've got to know
how to do those pieces.
And then we talked
most specifically
about a physical medium
that's close to what you're
doing in the lab, which
is the medium of, well,
an acoustic channel
driven by a loudspeaker,
and at the other
end are a microphone
to pick up the signal.
And I showed you these
typical characteristics
of loud speakers, the kinds that
you'll find listed everywhere,
three different speakers.
I mentioned last
time that, when you
look at frequency
specs for speakers,
people will typically only show
you the magnitude specification
because, for audio applications,
the phase distortions are
a little less important.
They tend to not be
picked up by the ear.
All of these-- let's see
they have passbands from--
this pointer's a
little weak here, but--
passbands from around 100 Hertz
to, let's say, 10 kilohertz.
So in that region, they pass
signals more or less uniformly
in at least the magnitude
characteristic, and then
near the edges they taper off.
And some speakers will
have bigger passbands,
and will taper off closer to DC.
Other speakers actually
will not pass frequencies
till you get till about, oh,
what is that, 120 Hertz or so
on this characteristic,
but you've
got to get way up before you get
anything through that speaker.
But nominally, we can
think of speakers,
since they're aimed at
audio applications--
what?
The ear here is something on the
order of, let's say, 100 Hertz
to 10 kilohertz.
OK, but the phase characteristic
is important, too.
It's not important,
maybe, when you're
talking about sending
audio on a speaker,
but in Audiocom in the
lab, you're actually
sending pulses across it.
You're communicating
something other than audio.
You're actually trying
to get a signal whose
particular shape matters.
It's not how you hear
it, but what it looks
like before you sample it, OK?
So in settings like that,
the phase characteristic
is important, as well.
Now, you haven't
explicitly probed
the frequency characteristic
of the speaker you're using.
You could do that,
but instead you've
been looking at things like step
responses in the time domain
and constructing eye
diagrams, but you
could look in the
frequency domain
and characterize your particular
channel for your laptop sitting
in a particular place.
You could look to see what the
magnitude and phase are like.
OK, so I want to go through
this exercise of looking
at the spectral
content of a signal
you want to get across
this audio channel,
and then looking at how the
audio channel shapes it,
and then what you pick
up at the other end.
So just to give you a feel for
how one thinks through this.
So the input in the
typical application
you have for Audiocom you have--
let's see, if you wanted to
signal just a 1 and then all
0's.
You would have 256
samples at height 1,
and then everything
from then on 0, OK?
So what I'd like to do is think
through how this pulse gets
across the medium, but thinking
it through in the frequency
domain, all right?
So the first thing
we have to figure out
is, what's the spectral
content of this pulse?
By the way, if we
understand it for one pulse,
then we can understand
it-- then we know it
for a sequence of
pulses because if we're
modeling the system as
time-invariant, once we figure
out what one pulse
does, we can figure out
what a later pulse will do.
It's just the same response
delayed in time, OK?
So the key to it
is understanding
what happens with one pulse.
So the spectral
content of the signal
is what we're interested in.
And my question is, do
you have any guesses
as to what the spectral
content might be, just roughly,
qualitatively?
Where do you think the energy
of the signal is concentrated?
What frequency ranges?
Any thoughts?
I'll need a hand up and a
loud voice so I can figure out
what's--
at least one?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Low frequency.
PROFESSOR: Low
frequency is a good idea
because, for most
of this signal,
you've got essentially
nothing happening, right?
It's just flat.
So you expect high
spectral content at DC.
But there is this
sharp transition,
so you might expect high
frequencies associated
with that.
So do you think it might
be low frequencies and then
high frequencies, not much
in between, or any thoughts?
OK, well, let's look
at what it actually is.
Let's work it out.
So we're talking about a
signal that's at height 1.
For-- let's do the general case.
So let's say it's for
n samples, so from 0
to n minus 1 its height 1, and
then it's 0 outside of that,
OK?
So suppose this is x of n.
How do we determine
the spectral content?
Well, we've got to write the--
we've got to compute
the DTFT, right?
So what's the DTFT?
It's a summation x m e to the
minus j omega m over all m.
But in this case, it
simplifies, right?
Because there are only a few
non-zero values of the signal.
So this is going to be--
let's see.
It's going to be x0 e to
the minus j omega 0 plus x1
e the minus j
omega 1, and so on.
That's going to be 1 plus
e to the minus j omega
plus e to the
minus j2 omega plus
e to the minus j
N minus 1 omega.
So that's the DTFT.
But till you work with
that and get it in a form
that you can make
sense of, you still
don't have a feel for where the
frequency content is, right?
You've got to--
the best way to get
at that is to think of what
the magnitude of this will be.
And even then, it's
not obvious how
to think about the magnitude
of a sum of complex numbers
like this, so you've got to
play with it a little more.
OK, well, this is a
geometric series, right?
Each term is obtained
from the previous one
by multiplying by to
the minus jam omega.
And so if you've got the
sum of a finite number
of geometric series of
this type, what do we have?
We have that as the sum, right?
You agree?
So this was the factor by
which we multiply each term.
Sorry.
And we've got N such
terms, so you're summing
N terms of a geometric series.
Well, we might be getting closer
here to extracting a magnitude,
but you really want to do a
little bit more massaging here.
Let's see.
If I make this e to
the j omega N over 2,
then here's e to the
j omega N over 2,
minus e to the minus
j omega N over 2.
And this is a trick we've done--
we've played a few times before.
Right?
I've just rearranged things.
Let's see.
How have I helped myself here?
Have I helped myself at all?
So what is-- what
does that simplify to?
Well, the factor in front I
can write as some phase term e
to the minus j omega
N minus 1 over 2.
And what's this?
Anybody?
Numerator?
Does the numerator
remind you of anything?
Sine?
Sine omega N over 2?
And the denominator,
sine omega over 2, right?
So now it starts to look a
little bit more manageable.
If I wanted to get
the magnitude of this,
well, the magnitude
of this is going
to be the magnitude of this
piece times the magnitude
of that piece.
What's the magnitude
of the first term here?
Just 1, right?
It's e to the j something,
so its magnitude is 1.
So here's the
magnitude of the DTFT,
so that's the spectral
characteristic,
and that's something
that we can plot.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Sorry.
Question, hi.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Say that again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Did I make a
mistake somewhere here, or?
Oh, this thing?
This term here?
I was trying to combine
numerator and denominator here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Which part?
Sorry.
I have to stand
where you are to see
if I made a mistake because
it's hard to see close up.
AUDIENCE: Over the-- like,
when we go from the 1 minus e
to the minus 2 again
to the other one,
why are we dividing by two?
PROFESSOR: Oh, what are we-- oh.
Why are we dividing by 2?
Because when you multiply it
out, that's what it takes.
I'm trying to group things to
get something interpretable.
I don't know what
this is, but I know
what the numerator
over sine looks
like, so I'm trying to
make this a little bit more
equally distributed, right?
So if I pull out that
factor, what's left?
Looks like part of a sine.
OK?
So I'm just-- so it's
this time this gives me
the numerator here.
And this times this gives
me the denominator here.
So it's just rearranging terms.
We've used this trick before.
Any trick that works
twice is a method, OK?
So we really have a method here.
It's not just a trick.
If it works three times, you
can make a religion of it.
OK, so that's the
derivation we have here.
What's the height of
this at the origin?
Let's just focus on that term.
OK, so this is the magnitude
we're talking about.
What's the height at the
origin, at omega equals 0?
Well, now you can use
L'Hopital's rule, right?
Because omega is something
that varies continuously.
So for small values of
the argument, you're
really looking at something
of height N. And then,
when is the first time
that this goes to 0?
Well, for small
values of frequency,
the numerator is
not changing sign,
and this first
goes to 0 when you
get to omega equals 2 pi
over N, to private capital N.
So actually, instead
of saying all that,
I should just draw
you a picture.
There's a picture of
one particular case.
So this is a case where,
actually, the pulse
didn't start at 0.
It was symmetrically
located around 0, OK?
It was a pulse of length 11
symmetrically located around 0.
And because it was
symmetrically located,
this phase factor went away,
and all you're left with
is the sine omega N over 2
divided by sine omega over 2.
So you're looking at the actual
DTFT of a pulse of that type,
OK?
So this started at minus
5 and went to plus 5,
and was 11 samples long and was
0 everywhere outside of that.
So that's what
this function looks
like, the sine omega N over 2
divided by sine omega over 2.
Does it remind you of a
function you've seen before?
Sinc?
A sinc function?
It's very close to a sinc.
The sinc, though, had just
frequency in the denominator.
It didn't have sine of
something in the denominator.
And the reason this
appears is, remember
that transforms and
frequency responses
have to be periodic
with period 2 pi.
So it certainly
wouldn't be possible
for the transform of
a signal to be a sinc
because there's no
periodicity in the sinc.
But when you work
it out carefully,
you find that it's
something close to a sinc,
but one that has exactly
the right periodicity,
so this thing will
repeat periodically
with period 2 pi, exactly
the way it's supposed to.
So it's sort of sinc-like.
For small values
of omega, the sine
is essentially
just omega over 2,
and it is essentially a sinc.
But when you get to
larger values of omega,
this thing starts
to play a role.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Does the
magnitude mean anything?
PROFESSOR: I haven't-- I'm not
plotting the magnitude now.
I was plotting the actual
DTFT for this case.
So in this symmetric
case, the actual DTFT
is the sine N omega over
2 over sine omega over 2.
So I was plotting
the actual DTFT.
And the magnitude of the
DTFT I get just by taking
absolute value, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, I did this
for a case of a pulse starting
at time 0, OK?
So this factor came
purely from where I
located this on the time axis.
So different positions of
this pulse on the time axis
will modify this factor but
won't touch this factor, OK?
Shifts in time correspond
to multiplication by e
to the minus j omega
something, right?
You've seen that in recitation.
So whenever you shift
the pulse in time,
what it does to the transform
is it leaves this part intact
and affects this
factor, but that
doesn't change the magnitude
of the transform, OK?
So in the case of a
symmetrical pulse,
symmetrical about
the origin, actually
that phase factor goes away,
and the actual transform
is just that piece without
the e to the anything.
Sorry.
I jumped over a few
steps in describing that.
Just to go back a second.
This is not a sinc
function, but it's actually
referred to as a periodic sinc.
It's got a fancier name, also.
It crops up all over the place.
Height N at the origin
and the first zero
crossing at 2 pi over cap N.
So as you make the pulse wider
in time, you make it
narrower in frequency, right?
As N becomes larger, you
make this wider in time.
The main lobe of this
frequency distribution
gets more concentrated,
and frequency gets
closer to being a DC signal.
Makes sense, right?
The longer that
this stays constant,
the more the signal looks
like just DC and the more
the frequency is
concentrated at the origin.
But what you can see
here is there's actually
a full spread of frequencies.
It's not that there's just low
frequency for the flat parts
and high frequency
for the vertical edge
and nothing in between.
There's actually a full
spread of frequency components
that it takes to
make up that step.
OK.
If you had a pulse
that wasn't centered--
this is just to show you.
Here is a pulse-- actually,
this is not centered.
It's only 10 long, but
the magnitude here you're
only seeing half the
frequency scale, so 0 to pi
essentially, except
this is in terms
of f, which is omega over 2 pi.
You get the same kind of
magnitude characteristic,
but now because you've
shifted it off-center,
you've got a linear-phase
characteristic,
and what you're seeing here is
a linear-phase characteristic,
except every time you
have a flip in sign,
you jump the phase by
180 degrees, right?
When you change the
sign of something
from a plus to a minus,
that's like adding 180 degrees
to the phase or subtracting
180 degrees to the phase.
So you can spend time on all
of this and make sense of it.
But the basic idea is that you
get the sinc-like distribution
and frequency.
OK, so let's get back to
the particular pulse that's
of interest to us,
which is that pulse.
So it's the same kind of
thing, except N is 256.
And what I've
plotted for you here
is the magnitude of the DTFT.
It has the sinc-like shape.
I haven't actually plotted it as
a continuous function of omega.
Instead, I've used the FFT.
You remember?
We talked about the
Fast Fourier Transform.
So what the fast Fourier
transform is going to do
is, if the actual magnitude
DTFT was some continuous thing
like this, the fast
Fourier transform
is going to give me samples
of it, as many as I want.
But the more samples
I ask for, the more
work I have to
do, of course, OK?
I asked for 48,000
samples of the DTFT
so that I could get a
nice big spread here.
If your samples came from
sampling at 48 kilohertz,
for instance, then
the rightmost end
that corresponds to pi in
terms of actual frequency
would correspond to the
sampling frequency divided by 2,
so that's 24 kilohertz
sitting there.
So I actually have 24,000
points for 24,000 Hertz,
so I've got one point
at every Hertz position,
but I could pick anything else.
The other thing I
wanted to mention
was that the reason
I could do this
is because I'm using the FFT.
Because I told you
if I just did sort
of simple-minded
implementation of the formula,
I would take order p
squared computations,
where p is the length of the
signal that I'm looking at.
If I use the FFT, I
go from p squared to--
I go down to p log to the
base 2 of p, all right?
Well, the number of points
I have here is 48,000,
so going from p to log 2 p is
going from 48,000 to 16, which
is a factor of 3,000.
So the difference is I'm
sitting at the terminal
and I hit the Return
key to get the FFT,
and maybe at 0.1
seconds later, I
get the answer,
versus if I didn't
use the FFT I'd
wait five minutes,
and then I wouldn't be
trying to put together
these figures for you.
OK, so the FFT really makes
a real practical difference,
and it really revolutionized
how numerical computations
were done.
OK, so here you now see the
full spectral distribution
if you're willing
to let your eye
interpolate between these
samples that I've got.
You see the full
spectral distribution
of that rectangular pulse, OK?
So a short pulse in time.
It's got certainly
high DC content,
but it's got tremendous
frequency distribution, all
the way out to high frequencies.
In fact, all the way to the end.
You're still seeing
frequency content.
It's visible to the eye.
So all the way out
to 24,000 Hertz,
and you could keep
going all right?
This is not a sinc.
It's a sinc-like function
because if you extended it,
it would go back up again.
It's got that period, 2
pi, exactly as it should.
But for all intents
and purposes,
for small values of frequency,
the sine omega over 2 here--
this is essentially
omega over 2,
and this is a
sinc-like function, OK?
Now, this is different
from what you saw before.
Before you had a constant
segment and frequency.
At least, I think it's
different from what
you've seen before,
unless you've
done examples in recitation.
But before what we
had was, for instance,
trying to get a
frequency response that
was like this, right?
We ended up with a unit
sample response that
was a sinc function in time.
This is going the other way.
This is a rectangular
function in time,
giving rise to a sinc-like
distribution in frequency.
All right.
Let's zoom in a little bit
just to see what we have here.
And this is exactly what
we expect to be seeing,
the sinc-like distribution.
The height there is
256, as it should be.
That's the N. And then
this should be at 2 pi
over capital N. If you
translate that to what it means
in actual frequency, this first
null there is at 187.5 Hertz.
That's 48 kilohertz
divided by N, so that's--
OK, so that's that number.
So that gives you some
idea of how this thing is
spread in frequency.
OK, so if this pulse is applied
directly to the loudspeaker--
well, here, the
loudspeaker passband
goes from about 100 Hertz
to, let's say, 10,000 Hertz.
You see there's huge
amounts of the energy that's
not in the passband
of the loudspeaker.
All right?
So this is not going to do very
well if you just directly apply
that pulse to the loudspeaker.
You have to match the
frequency content of the input
to the frequency response
of the system you're
trying to get this over.
OK.
Now, just as an
experiment before we
get back to sending this
across a loudspeaker,
let's take a look
at what happens
if we send that rectangular
pulse over a lowpass channel.
So let's save the
bandpass channel, which
is a little more
involved, for later,
and just look at
what happens if we
send this pulse over
a lowpass channel.
So I'm thinking about a
channel whose frequency
characteristic--
this is h of omega--
it passes low
frequencies, and then it
truncates higher frequencies.
OK?
And what I'm going to
do is send in an x of N,
which is this pulse in time.
256 at height 1, and
then everything 0.
All right, so if I'm thinking
of it in the frequency domain,
then I take the spectral content
of the signal, which we've just
worked out, and multiplied
by the frequency response
characteristic, which
just basically selects out
the frequency content
that's in the passband
and rejects everything else.
And then that gives me the
spectral content of the output,
and I can translate
that back to what
happens in the time domain.
So here is-- well, actually,
let's take a zoomed-in version.
I've taken a lowpass filter,
where this cutoff corresponds
to actually a
cutoff at 400 Hertz
if you're thinking in terms
of the underlying waveform.
So what we've done is take
the rectangular pulse,
put it through a
lowpass filter--
and I'm assuming an
ideal lowpass filter--
passes everything in this
frequency band and nothing
outside of it, OK?
So here again, we see
we're selecting out
part of the spectral
structure of the input,
but there's huge
amounts of the energy
of the input that
are being left out
of the output of the filter.
Now, in the time domain, look
at what this corresponds to.
It's an approximation
to this pulse,
but it's one in which all the
high-frequency content has
disappeared because we've only
let the low-frequency pieces
through.
So what you have is a very
rounded kind of pulse.
It spreads out well over the 256
mark, so here's the 0 to 256,
but this thing actually spills
over into adjacent bit slots.
We've taken out the
high-frequency components,
so it can't make any
sharp turns anymore.
It's got this
lower-frequency wiggling.
As you can imagine, if I
made this even smaller,
my wiggling would become
even more leisurely here,
and I would spill further into
the adjacent bit slots, OK?
So this is what
lowpass filtering will
do to that rectangular pulse.
Any questions on this piece?
OK.
Now, we've actually seen
examples of this type.
I flashed these up last time.
It's the same idea, except it
was not just a single pulse.
It was a succession
of pulses like this.
So you could do the same thing.
Have a succession
of pulses like this.
Take its DTFT to assess
the spectral content.
I'm showing you not actually the
DTFT but something proportional
to it here.
This is-- so ignore
the labels there.
Think of this as
essentially the DTFT.
To within the
scale factor it is.
So you can see that I
have spectral content
all the way out to the edges.
But now send it through
a lowpass channel
which zeros out all
the spectral content
outside of some central
region, and what
you have coming
out the other end
is something that can't take
the sharp turns anymore,
so it's much more rounded.
And as you narrow it
down still further,
you get even more rounding,
and you get a spilling over.
You see this sharply confined
rectangular pulse now spills
over into the adjacent slots.
And you can go still
further on that.
The top plot here is the
same as the bottom plot
in the previous one.
But this is just
showing the sequence.
So as you narrow it down
further and further and further,
what comes out
the other end gets
much less distinctive
in its features, OK?
It can only-- this only has
very low-frequency content,
so it can't do any sharp turns.
And this is an eye
diagram corresponding to--
in each of these
received signals-- just
to show you how
detection gets difficult
if you've got a lowpass
channel and you've got
this pulse that's
not well-defined.
Now, how might you actually--
how might you get a
better-defined pulse
for a given channel?
So if I gave you this channel--
we sent in this pulse
of length 256 samples,
and we got something that
we didn't like because it
spilled over into other slots.
The reason it spilled
into other slots
is we were cutting out too
much of its spectral content.
What could you do to this
pulse to get more of its energy
across that bandpass channel?
Yeah?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Set a longer pulse.
PROFESSOR: Set a longer pulse.
How does that work?
Now, you see, if
you make N longer,
you make the pulse longer, you
shrink this correspondingly
in the frequency domain, right?
We said that on these
sinc-type characteristics,
the height was N.
This first null was
2 pi over N. Make
the pulse longer,
you pull the main lobe in
tighter, and more of this
is going to go through, OK?
And you can see that clearly.
That's something you can
explore in your experiment.
So if you wanted to get
more clearly defined
output for a given
lowpass channel,
you might want to increase
the length of your pulse.
Of course, that's going to
slow down your signaling rate,
so there's a trade-off
involved, right?
Now, we've actually--
this is just
to sort of step back and point
out that what we're seeing here
are some properties that are
inherent to Fourier transforms,
OK?
So it's typically the
case that if you've
got a signal that's wide in
time, it's narrow in frequency.
And if you make
it wider in time,
it gets narrower in frequency.
In fact, as I mentioned
up there, the uncertainty
principle in physics really
comes from this result.
It says that the spread in time
times the spread in frequency
has some lower bound, OK?
So this is some number
that's strictly positive.
So you can't make a signal
arbitrarily concentrated
in time and concentrated
in frequency.
If you make one
small, the other one
will have to grow
correspondingly.
So actually, the uncertainty
principle in physics
is precisely a theorem
in Fourier transforms
if you study it.
Here is another such
complementarity or duality.
The smoother you make a
signal in time, the more sharp
it is in frequency.
Let's see.
We saw that here,
for instance, right?
We had a signal in time,
namely the unit sample
response of the ideal filter.
This was-- this didn't
have any sharp edges to it.
It was a sinc function.
You got something
that's smooth in time,
it ends up having sharp
edges in frequency, OK?
And the more smooth
you make it in time,
the sharper it
gets in frequency.
And this we've already seen.
This is the kind of trade-off
we're talking about.
So these are characteristics
to be on the lookout for.
In fact, I just did a
little experiment here.
What if we decided not to try
and send a rectangular pulse
over, but we smoothed out
the pulse a little bit
to get rid of that sharp edge?
So that's another way
that you can try and get
a pulse over a lowpass
channel like this.
So you see, what
I'm trying to do
is not have the sharp
discontinuities, the 0 to 1
and the 1 to 0.
I want a more rounded
behavior in the time domain
so I get a sharper concentration
in the frequency domain,
and you can actually
see how that works.
So what I've actually done here
is, instead of a signal that--
well, if you'll
permit me, I don't
want to draw these stem
plots, the lollipop figures,
because they get painful
to draw, but just assume
that this is 256 such things.
That's the rectangular pulse
we were trying to send before.
What I've done now
is instead say,
well, let me around
the edges, so I'm
going to have a half cycle of
a cosine for that edge, OK?
So that's what--
these are the samples
I'm going to use at
this edge, and I'm
going to have a half-cycle
of a cosine at this edge.
This is actually something
that's used quite a bit
in applications.
All right, so what have I done?
I've removed the
sharp edge and gotten
a much-rounded transition.
In fact, if you're thinking
of continuous functions,
the original had
a discontinuity,
whereas here I've got to
take two derivatives before I
encounter a discontinuity
because the function itself
and its slope at these
ends are well-matched,
so I've got to
differentiate twice
before I get a discontinuity.
So actually, it has quite
some smoothness to it.
Smooth in time means
more tightly concentrated
in frequency.
So all I'm doing
on the next slide
is showing you, so
your eye can compare,
what the spectral content
is of the original pulse
and of this rounded pulse.
And for the rounded
pulse, I actually
just flipped it over so that
you can compare more easily.
So this is the negative
of the DTFT magnitude
of the shaped pulse.
And you can sort of
see right away here
that the frequency content
has essentially settled out.
It's almost all contained
in this smaller region,
whereas the
rectangular pulse had
a frequency content that went
way off to high frequencies,
right?
Went off to 24 kilohertz,
for instance, in our example.
So the frequency content
of the shaped pulse
is much more tightly
contained, and you
have a much better
chance of getting that
across a lowpass channel.
So this is just a
little bit of shaping
that can make a big
difference in terms
of adapting the signal you're
trying to send to the channel.
So if I look in the time
domain, sending these two
pulses over the same
lowpass channel,
you can do a visual
comparison of what comes out.
So here's the original 256
rectangular pulse coming out
the other end.
Here is my shaped pulse
coming out the other end.
And you can see the shaped pulse
is much more tightly confined
in the bit slot that
I assigned to it,
so it's much more
tightly confined
around the 256-sample width, OK?
So this is another
thing that is done,
and it's done by thinking
in the frequency domain.
People designed
these pulses thinking
in the frequency domain.
They're not doing convolution.
OK, that was all
lowpass, but we want
to look at bandpass, so just a
couple of quick examples there.
So we're back to the speakers.
And we're taking our
rectangular pulse
and applying it to the speaker.
So here's what the spectrum
looks like after ideal bandpass
filtering.
So I'm not actually
filtering with the speaker
characteristic.
I'm assuming an
ideal bandpass that
extends from 100
Hertz to 10,000 Hertz
and zeros out everything
outside that range.
So I send in the
spectral characteristic
of my rectangular pulse.
I shape it with the bandpass.
So what comes out is
something that has
this spectral characteristic.
And you can see that the
frequency content is sharply
limited 10 kilohertz
above 0, and then there
is actually a central region
that's entirely missing.
So remember, this had to
go originally up to 256,
but because we've chopped
out the center portion,
we're only going out to
150-something out there.
So actually, if I
zoom in, you can
see that a lot more closely.
So this is a zoomed-in
version of what
comes out from a loudspeaker,
from a bandpass filter,
if I send in a
rectangular pulse.
The very low frequencies
are entirely missing,
and we saw in the
previous characteristic
that the very high frequencies
are missing, as well.
So what's the shape of the
pulse that you get out?
Not very good.
Because the low
frequencies are missing,
this thing tends to
sag in the middle.
It can't hold up DC.
And it can't make the very
sharp transitions, either,
so there is a more
leisurely transition.
But again, this can't
stay at that level.
It actually asymptotes.
So the actual pulse occupies--
before it settles, occupies way
over the 256 bits that
I've allotted to it, OK?
So taking that rectangular
pulse and directly putting it
on the speaker is going to
give you something not pretty
at the other end and something
that you cannot signal with.
So the question is what
to do about that, OK?
And the answer to that is this
thing that we call modulation.
We've already seen it
in different forms.
Let's think about it now
in the frequency domain.
OK, so here's what
we're going to do.
Want the big stick of chalk.
OK.
We're going to shape the
spectral characteristics
of the signal.
We started off with some
time-domain signal links, x N,
corresponding DTFT x omega.
It wasn't well-matched to
our channel characteristics,
and so what we're
going to do is multiply
by some carrier frequency.
And this is simple
amplitude modulation.
We're just referring to
it as modulation here.
We get some signal out here.
And the question is, what is
the frequency characteristic
of that signal?
OK, we've already seen
what the frequency
characteristic of the input is.
What's the frequency
characteristic of that signal?
So just to give you an
example, we had our x of omega
looking something
like the sinc shape.
Remember height N there?
And the question is, what's
the spectrum of this?
And there's a
computation up there
that I don't want to go
through, but it shows you
that the answer is
actually quite simple.
So if I call this--
let me call this t
of N because it's
the signal we're
going to transmit.
Here's what the spectrum of the
transmitted signal looks like.
There is omega.
There's pi.
Here's omega c.
OK, so the
prescription is simple.
Take the spectral characteristic
and replicate it at omega c
and replicate it at minus
omega c, and scale by 1/2.
So what you're going to get
is this characteristic here,
this characteristic here, and
the height will be N over 2.
It's that simple.
So you can go through the math.
When you're done with
the math, what it says
is that the spectral
characteristic
of this modulated signal is
the spectral characteristic
of the envelope of the baseband
signal, or the envelope,
but translated to the
position of the carrier.
So you can begin
to see how this is
going to help us shift
a signal to get it
across a bandpass channel.
We started off
with something that
was not well-suited to the
loudspeaker we now have a way
to shift its energy
to get it right
in the passband of the
speaker by picking the carrier
frequency appropriately.
All right?
I think I'm going to
skip some of this.
But let's look at
what this does.
It's really this
picture, but I just
want to show you how it
works with actual waveforms.
So here is the rectangular
pulse times the cosine.
I've picked-- what did I pick?
1 kilohertz as my carrier?
Yeah.
1,000 Hertz was the carrier.
1,000 Hertz sits comfortably
in the passband of a speaker,
so it's a reasonable choice.
By the way, in typical AM,
the carrier frequencies
are much higher
than-- or the ratio
of the carrier frequency
to the rate of variation
of the envelope is
much higher than what
we have in these examples.
So the audio channel is
actually very challenging.
OK, so this is my
modulated signal.
The question is, what does
its spectrum look like?
So I run it through
the FFT, and indeed I
get the replication here.
Let's zoom in a
little bit so we can
see it a little more closely.
So what I have is those
two sinc-like spectral
characteristics, but translated
to sit centered at 1,000
Hertz and minus 1,000 Hertz.
Remember that this
is 0 out here, OK?
And the height,
well, it's now it's
128, which is half the
256 that I had before.
So in terms of positioning
this within where
the loudspeaker
will transmit it,
we were taking the lower
cutoff of the loudspeaker
as being around 100 Hertz.
This is where 100 Hertz sits.
So you can see
that a huge amount
of the energy of the
pulse is getting through.
It's at the wrong frequencies.
We'll have to deal
with getting it back.
But at least getting the energy
across is working here, OK?
And the upper cutoff of the
speaker is way off over here.
So this is 10,000,
but I'm showing you
a zoomed-in version, so the
upper frequency is way off.
In fact, that also
brings up the idea
that you could actually do
this trick multiple times.
You could actually pick another
carrier frequency somewhat
higher than this with some
other modulating signal on it
and tuck that in there, as well.
So you could simultaneously
transmit messages
on multiple carriers
through that same speaker,
and you'll be exploring
that, as well.
OK.
So what does the-- what's
the time-domain signal that
corresponds to this looks like?
So when you get it, you
impress this modulated signal
on the loudspeaker, on
this bandpass filter.
What's the output of
the bandpass filter?
You can see it's almost
exactly what you put in, OK?
There's a little
bit of distortion
at the different places,
but it's basically exactly
the pulse that you put in.
So almost all the
energy has gone through,
and you don't have
significant distortion
because you've squarely
placed the energy
in the passband of the filter.
OK, now how do we recover?
How do we get back the
original baseband signal?
Well, it turns out
it's very easy.
Let me actually
do it in pictures,
and then we'll look at the math.
This is what's coming
in to our receiver,
and now we've got to process
this to get back a signal that
has this spectrum.
We've learned a trick,
which is modulation.
Multiply it by a cosine,
and you'll take the spectrum
and replicate it at omega
c and at minus omega c.
I'm going to use the
same trick again.
I'm going to take the
received signal multiplied
by a cosine of the
same carrier frequency,
and what's that going to do?
Well, my scale is getting
bigger here each time.
So here's my omega c.
Here's my minus omega c.
What's coming in is this signal.
I'm going to multiply it
by cosine omega c, so what
does that do in the spectrum?
It takes this spectrum,
replicates it at omega c.
So what does that do?
Well, it puts a piece here,
and it puts a piece here,
at 2 omega c, right?
Because I've taken
this spectrum--
you've got to imagine
the change of scale
so I can draw all of this.
I've taken this
spectrum and I've
placed it centered on omega c.
And this is now--
this is the N over 2 here.
Oh, but now it's going
to be N over 4, right?
Because I divide by 2.
And then I take
the same spectrum
and I center it
on minus omega c.
OK, so I've got
the N over 4 piece
here, but I'm going
to have the other--
oh, sorry.
I drew it in the wrong place.
I'm going to center
it at omega c.
So this is going to end
up at minus 2 omega c.
And the replication here.
So there's going to be a second
one sitting here at the origin.
So the net effect
at the origin is
that I get the original
spectrum, but scaled by a half,
and then I get vestiges
of this, if you like,
centered at twice the
carrier frequency, OK?
And that's actually
what the algebra shows.
The algebra is very simple.
You're receiving this.
Multiply it again by a cosine.
So take the received signal and
multiply it again by a cosine.
Well, if you substitute for
what the received signal is,
you get x n times
cosine squared.
Cosine squared, if you
use a standard identity,
splits into these two terms.
Let's see.
Do I have that right?
Yeah.
So here's the 0.5 x n
sitting here at the origin,
and here's another term,
which is x n times the cosine.
So this is like a
modulated signal,
but modulated by twice
the carrier frequency.
So what does this translate to?
Well, it's actually 0.5 times
x n times cosine 2 omega c.
What does that do in
the spectral domain?
It's going to take half of
that and place it at minus 2
omega c and plus 2 omega
c, so it's completely
consistent with this picture.
So what is it that we
have to do now to extract
the signal of interest?
Just a lowpass
filtering here, OK?
So if you can select out this
piece with a lowpass filter,
you've recovered the
signal of interest.
You can adjust the
scale factor, too,
so you can have a lowpass
filter with a gain of 2
and you've recovered
your original signal.
All right, we'll
build on Monday.
And that'll be the last
lecture on this material.
Relative to the calendar,
we're just sliding forward,
so we'll wrap up
this stuff on Monday
and then continue with packets.